the first time we try is when we try it
right in
and when we are betting all those years
of
work and sacrifice in seven minutes
that's why we call the seven minutes of
terror one of the many reasons
is that the we haven't done it
essentially we have to do it the
computer is going to do it but you have
it
right exactly so then that's why we are
so concerned that it's not going to work
because if we
forgot a little piece of physics we have
a small error
in that simulation that doesn't expose
our
our mistake then mars will tell us
about our mistake and it's too late by
then and i i know that feeling when you
work so hard on something and there's an
element of luck to it or
or circumstance but when it hits it's
it's the best feeling in the world
we are humans after all you know with
emotions and sometimes
uh when we after we finish doing all
that we can do with our brain
right then the heart takes over right
and it starts telling you things
and making you lose sleep at night and
then you got to say no but wait a second
i know that
this is the same as before and we tested
this and we tested and these guys did a
tremendous job in there
and i trust them and they work really
hard and i saw them doing it
so then you kind of the brain takes over
again
and tells the heart you know we're gonna
be fine but then when you land it's all
about the heart right it's not about the
brain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back to your next
episode of yang speaks the future of our
limited series i'm your co-host zach
grauman i was andrew's campaign manager
and now you're stuck with me diving into
this limited series on our future today
guys and gals we are talking about the
future of space
and it's freaking awesome so i hope
you're excited because you should be
excited
we have someone who i don't think ever
does
any sort of public appearances but he
happened to be
a fan of this movement campaign and
took about an hour of his time to give
us
inside scoop on the future of space the
man's name is miguel
san martin he's from argentina
originally
and he is a engineer at nasa works in
the nasa's he's lead engineer in the
guidance control section at nasa's
jet propulsion lab but he is mainly
known folks
for getting mars rovers on to mars
getting the rovers there and he just got
the perseverance rover which most recent
rover we got onto the planet mars
we talk about the future of space and
how this all works with him we talk
about how the rover was built and what
it does and what it's going to do when
it's there and how you get it onto the
planet but we also talk about what this
means
is there life on mars what are we
looking to find when we get there why
are we doing this
what does the future of space look like
guys
i learned a ton on this podcast i don't
normally
ask for our guests like deep background
but in this case
i talk about his story because his story
and how he went from
literally looking at the stars in
argentina to
navigating the stars with the mars rover
in the united states is
wild you're going to learn a ton i
learned a ton we're also going to talk
about what is going on
in the future of our humanity in the
cosmos like this is
everything it's so i geeked out a little
bit so pardon me for being a bit of a
fanboy but i thought this was wild it's
so important
so tune in guys the future of space
only on yang speaks
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks today we are
talking about the future of space
and the goal of this episode is to blow
everyone's mind including my own
today i am so excited i want to welcome
the amazing miguel san martin who's an
engineer at nasa
best known for his work right now he's
the chief engineer for guidance
the guidance and control section at
nasa's jet propulsion lab
and had a lot to do with the latest
mission to mars and the mars
perseverance rover so miguel
thank you for joining sir it's good to
be with you good to be with you too
the first thing i learned about you is
how fascinating your background is um
so tell me tell me a little bit about
you and some of the um how you got to be
a nasa
engineer okay well i grew up in
argentina
i was actually uh i was born in a in
in a farm in the old-fashioned way
in the in 1959
but my family lived in the farm by the
time i was born we lived in borosilis
but we spent
all the vacations summer vacations and
winter vacations in the farm
and for me that was always a this is in
the patagonia and uh
it was always a place where i went to
dream i mean we have a beautiful
sky you know at night and
my father was a civil engineer and uh
from you know where bill rhodes in the
in the
uh late 30s in the patagonia you know
and and
in order to to navigate didn't have gps
right so they used the stars
so he had taken classes on
uh on you know how to use stars to
navigate through the patagonia so he
would teach me at night
all the different constellations and the
different stars so i think that that's a
little bit where
you know my dream started the other
thing is that
i was kind of born an engineer i guess
and that it was out of my control that's
the way i
was i was wired um
at very early age you know um i
i loved everything that had electronics
and mechanical
things um and everything was
you know i would take apart everything
and not always put it back together the
way it was
and and my father used to you know
encouraged me all the time with these
things i will buy uh
education educational toys at a very
early age
and uh and this was the time of this of
of of apollo so i grew up with apollo
i was 10 years old when i saw neil
armstrong walk on the moon
and i had a you know i saw it live you
know and uh
had a massive impact right and at that
point is when i said oh
i can i knew i was going to be an
engineer i just didn't know what type of
engineer i was going to be
and applied to what right and that's
when i started well maybe i can work
on this right but the thing that sealed
the deal for me was viking
that was the first um lander on mars
in 1976 and uh
and i also followed that mission very
closely i actually just happened
that it was on on the uh the landing of
viking
uh happens when we were at the farm we
used to go on the winter we used to go
for for two weeks and uh and it was kind
of
uh where we would kill two pigs and then
we'll make the prosciutto and and
sausages and which by the way you know i
i
i used to complain right or here we were
you know
doing this primitive stuff where these
other countries are going to mars and
they're going to mars yeah
but in any case i i remember following
um
the viking project through the bbc at
night and uh and
shortwave and i remember the night where
they said well all systems are go
everything is green
and uh you know viking is landing a few
hours and good night this is the end of
the
of the of the the program right so i
i woke up in the the next morning and
went to the town to
to do the usual things that we bought
you know the
bread for the day and and the newspaper
and there in the newspaper was
viking footpath on the surface of mars
right and i said
this is what i want to do that's it i'm
done i i
figured it out i was 16 years old
so my father at that point said you know
the only way that you're going to be
able to fulfill your dreams is you
probably need to go to your
university studies uh in the united
states and that will
you know make it a little easier perhaps
to to get to nasa and do your things so
so that's when i you know i i decided
that i had to do that so i finished high
school
did my back my backs and i came with
zero
plans the only plans that i had when i
left
was to study english as a second
language
to do the process of getting accepted in
in an american university and syracuse
accepted me so that was my
my entrance to university university and
i did my undergraduate in
electrical engineering and and i did
very well i was summa [ __ ] landed and
then i applied to mit
and they accepted me so that's where i
got my graduate degree
in aeronautics and astronautics and that
that opened
the door to to nasa because essentially
i study
with professors that work on the apollo
project let's talk about when you first
get to nasa what are the first couple
things you started to work on i feel
like there's so many
space projects that happen i mean look
we barely talk about the mars rover i
guess is what's bothering me
um and i'm sure there's so many cool
things you've worked on that
people are just unaware of what did you
get to do oh yeah right not in the best
time to arrive because
uh they were working on on a mission a
huge mission called galileo
that uh that orbited jupiter so they
were at the end
of of galileo uh you know
development and so i kind of missed the
party you know it was a little too late
and there was nothing in the horizon at
that point
right so uh but what i did is i you know
i started getting memos and
learning about galileo so i learned you
know try to
you know all the experts were there i
mean the world experts on this stuff so
i was trying to extract all the
information that i could
in preparation for when the big
opportunity came in
i worked in a couple of of missions uh
uh wonder was it was actually an earth
orbiting mission to study the
the altitude of the of the oceans you
know and actually that that mission
even though it didn't go to mars uh it
was a pioneer
in the uh in doing studies about the la
nina and
el nino the currents of ocean currents
my
first big break was cassini that was a
huge mission
uh to orbit at saturn so that was really
my first contribution
on the product that actually was carried
on the spacecraft wasn't
it was a piece of software and algorithm
to determine
guess what i worked on a piece of
software that determined the orientation
of the vehicle relative to the stars so
i kind of like
closed circle with full screen i used to
navigate in the patagonia so that was
pretty cool
and um so then so that was my big
big first break for me and and then
right after that
uh you know actually we were in the
middle of developing cassini when
uh when my boss called me to his office
and said look there is this
new mission to go to mars it's called
mars pass finder
they don't have any money to do it some
people think it's not going to work it's
going to use this airbag concept so it
was
not going to light like viking right so
that was kind of
you know a little shocked you know
because for for me viking was
everything right so what do you mean you
you know what i'll land like viking
no it's too expensive so we're going to
use the air box okay fine you're still
going to land on mars
viking it was considered in in the 70s
the robotic equivalent of the apollo
project today
viking would have been a six billion
dollar plus
mission right so that it was that big
right
they had to invent everything you know
how to land on mars i mean it's
we're still using you know pieces of the
viking like the parachute design
is still a viking design for all our
rover missions since then
so they have to actually develop
computers
for space you know sophisticated
computers to be able to land on mars
so uh and so it was a soft lander it was
by softlander we mean that vehicle
actually the you know enters in contact
with the ground
at a low velocity or you know lands on
legs
they have shock absorbers just to you
know
uh uh to soften the impact of landing
right but it comes out at very low
speeds but that requires very
sophisticated navigation
components and and and like a radar
to compute the velocity of the vehicle
route it to the ground and
engines that you can throttle so you can
you know
uh like like the accelerator in your car
you can regulate the thrust
and lands softly when
vik when mars pass finder comes in right
it was part of the faster better and
cheaper
mantra of nasa they told us take more
risks
uh and uh and make it much cheaper so
the thought was at that point
that trying to do a soft lander
like viking would cost too much money
because you have to develop all these
even though those things were invented
you know 20 years before
just resurrecting all that technology
will cost so much money
we didn't have it so my colleagues and
friends now
from mechanical engineering said well
maybe instead of having all these
complex and expensive navigation
equipment we can just land on an airbag
and let it bounce
so that was the idea so in some ways uh
try to minimize the the use of the
techniques that i
i'm an expert right because i actually i
am
my area is about using sensors and
actuators to control the vehicle right
it was robust if you land on top of a
rock
right i mean if you if you line with a
legged lander
on top of a rock you can actually break
the land or
topple it right i mean in that upside
down an airbag system
is more robust to the uncertainty in the
terrain you know
so that's what we did and then that's
that was the invention of the airbag
landers
system that then we use for spear and
[Music]
opportunity
all right it's kovid and
on personal level i have been
looking to talk to somebody to stay sane
stay happy
um for me i think just the isolation has
been interfering with a lot of my
professional or personal goals
um makes me a different type of person
than i normally am and for those of you
who are struggling with that
i want to talk to you about better help
which is our sponsor here
on yang speaks betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist so you can connect
in a safe and private online environment
it's super convenient i've liked it a
lot
you can get professional counselors in
depression and anger and stress and
anxiety relationships and sleeping and
self-esteem and grief and
you name it it's available worldwide
it's really cool um
you can kind of dive in on what would be
helpful for you
what is needed for you and what you're
thinking and you don't have to go into a
public waiting room or anything like
that
it's all confidential so i've got an
offer for you if you want to start
living healthier living a happier life
today
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com so join over one million
people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelphelp.com
[Music]
let's talk about going from point a to
point b how do you in like layman's
terms like high level because i know you
specialize
in like the navigation of these projects
um but i think you have an interesting
perspective is how you go
from cape canaveral or wherever we're
launching from
um nasa to landing on a crater
on mars and the
the simple analogy i was looking at was
like
because the planets are orbiting both
around the sun
it seemed like imagine if you're a human
being riding a merry-go-round
and there was another merry-go-round
that circled
your merry-go-round and you were trying
to toss
an egg to somebody as you were moving
who's moving at a different speed and
then they had to catch it
perfectly you walk us through how you go
from
launching something here and to
physically landing on mars there are
different technologies but let's talk
about the one that is
more the most common right where
it's more very impulsive it's actually
uh it is similar to what you're saying
so if you imagine you have a rock in
your hand and then you have a moving
platform
that a car it is
kind of violent analogy but let's just
assume that i want to hit
a moving uh car with a rock right
so um you will have to try to guess the
velocity of the of the vehicle because
you need to
throw it where the the car is going yeah
right and uh so you have to calculate
how long the rock is gonna get
to where the vehicle is and where the
vehicle is gonna be by the time it
arrives
right so and but once that rock leaves
my hand
i'm done right there's no way to to
correct it so you have to do all your
calculations
by understanding where everything is and
what velocity
right so so the equivalent of the rock
is the launch vehicle
that you know that lands that that light
you know in a rock it takes
a fraction of a second you know in a
launch it takes
minutes maybe 10 minutes right and but
it's the same thing
that rocket is gonna put you in a
trajectory
it's gonna throw you in the trajectory
that at that point mars is not there
actually you're gonna throw it such that
at the right moment
mars is gonna uh run over it's like a
quarterback thrown into a receiver right
you gotta throw it
exactly yes you have to and he receives
he throws it where the guy is not
right and uh except that the receiver is
looking at the ball and he's trying to
intercept and mars doesn't care i don't
care
i'll try to you know right yeah so
you're going to keep moving regardless
good point
so then the where the analogy with
throwing the rock
breaks is that we actually do have the
capability of
of of from the ground using actually the
communication system of the vehicle
doubles
as a also a navigation
measurement so by making measurements
uh we can measure the distance and the
velocity of the vehicle and also the
angle of the vehicle and estimate the
trajectory so now we know
because when you throw the the rock
through you know with the rocket you
don't do a perfect job
so you know you try to but you quite not
right
right so we need to figure out where we
are in the trajectory
and then we can make small adjustments
to those trajectories so we
we have like in perseverance we have
five opportunities
right where we make which are already
pre-scheduled you know before we launch
the actually years before we launch
where we make those small corrections
the vehicle has a proposed
propulsive system on board that ask is
it just air or
gas that you're burning or what what
changes trajectory
it's a it's it's they are little rockets
and they're very simple they're called
it's a monopropylene propulsion system
it's just a single
fuel hydrazine that when he gets in
contact with this
uh with this cat bed that you know that
they call it
the it makes it a chemical reaction that
generates
heat and gases right so that
has a little nozzle and then that pushes
you around
so so by opening the valves of that
system you create a force
right and and then you make that that
correction in the trajectory and then
you check out again to see whether or
not
are we now in the right trajectory no we
need another tweak
right so we have five opportunities to
do that
during the flight um and so and slowly
we are necking down
on the trajectory the the first
persevering robbers by the way
the navigation was so incredibly
accurate that we didn't need the last
two
correctly so you only did three three
less we only did three and you were on
you were on point after the last two are
you why did it why is it five is it a
resource perspective is it how much fuel
or energy you have in the
in the you know the rover itself why why
five it but i mean it's it's a it's an
optimization you wanna try to minimize
the fuel
okay and then you wanna maximize the
accuracy or the delivery of the
trajectory
and you try to keep it simple right i
mean every time that you do these
maneuvers
it's an opportunity to screw up
right and maybe that's a good point more
things to go wrong yeah
more things to go wrong so we actually
for each one of these maneuvers the
reason why we didn't do the last two
right was because we have criteria to
say are we close enough
we don't have to be perfectly on the
trajectory so we have
a criteria that says no this is close
enough they are for
yeah we could make the maneuver and make
it even better
but better you know you know you could
actually
shoot yourself on the foot by deciding
to do something that you didn't have to
and you might end up worse off right so
then
it's just very disciplined we are always
measuring risk
right uh risk against risk right risk of
not making the correction with risk of
making the correction
i mean there's a lot of money involved
right we are billions of dollars and
time
and time it's what takes seven months
right seven months right now or so
yes and you take six to eight years of
sacrifice
just to attempt one of these things
right so imagine the sacrifice of all
these people their families
right that evaporates because of the bad
decision
so um so that's how we navigate so and
also we
obviously we not only we are concerned
about the trajectory of the vehicle
but the orientation is very important
because we have solar arrays so they
need to point
towards the sun and then the antenna
needs to be pointed towards the earth
that's why we need this system that by
looking at the sun
direction and the stars can figure out
its orientation
so see what the stars is canopus is
there sirius is there
therefore earth is in that direction so
that is that control of the orientation
and the control of the translation
that's what we do during
during the the trip to mars in addition
to
always checking that all the systems are
working and the system that we're going
to need for the
the landing are are going to be ready to
operate and they are all calibrated so
so those are the activities
that we do during the cruise phase
that's what we call it
the trip from earth to to mars so it
starts on a rocket and then the rover is
still attached to some form of
ship as it's in the cruise phase right
like it's that's right it's in
an aeroshell which is like it's like a
capsule right
because the there are three phases of of
of
deceleration one with a ride to mars we
arrive to mars
at a 15 000 miles an hour when we arrive
to the
upper layers of the atmosphere and there
are three
three um stages of slowing down right
the first stage is just simply this
capsule
uh enters the atmosphere and just simply
because it
is wide and it has a large area with a
friction with the air
right it slows down just like if in the
car you know
if you're driving a car don't do this
kids but if you put your hand you're
gonna
feel the resistance right that uh that
that that is pushing it's just the the
the
you know the drag of your hand through
the flow of the of
of the wind right the same with that but
much higher velocities and that friction
generates a lot of heat so you're
changing kinetic energy which is the
energy of motion
with thermal energy right so
you need a heat shield that can actually
protect the the spacecraft from that
huge you know thousand degrees of of
heating right so that's the first stage
99
of all the energy you you you lose it in
that first stage
so then we open a parachute supersonic
parachute
and we all know how parachute works and
uh
and that slowed you even more but you
you still
because the atmosphere of mars is so
tenuous
right it is one only one percent density
compared to earth
so the parachute so even with a nice big
parachute
you know 21 meter parachute you're still
coming pretty fast like 200 miles an
hour
right so you need a third phase which is
when you get rid of the parachute and
now you have
these engine you know that uh
and then it's propulsively you kill the
rest of your velocity and you land
softly just like viking did all of this
is
totally automated and uh there's too
many minutes you know
it takes too long for to send him like
seven minutes oh so this is like
time this is because yeah how long does
it take for a message to get to
the rover from earth yeah about seven
minutes okay that's too long
seven minutes back right so actually
when when we get the telemetry that the
thing is about to land it actually
he already landed so uh you're
celebrating seven minutes later
exactly but it's weird to think like oh
you know the the dice have been tossed
it's just we don't know the answer yet
and uh and uh so we
i mean we are used to now thinking that
reality is what we
see right so right we kind of not think
about that other stuff
[Music]
all right i want to talk about debt on a
personal level i've had some debt
i had about 200 or so grand in student
loan debt i had to pay off and i got out
of college and then what happens if you
have debt is you start
to get other types of debt including
credit card debt and i want to talk to
you about
upstart because upstart is a fast and
easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt all online it's like a debt
consolidator and they use a better
algorithm to figure out your actual
credit score
so if you're doing credit cards or high
interest debt or personal expenses or
student loan debt all these things
over half a million people use upstart
to get simple fixed monthly
payments which i like you put it all in
one place they find smarter rates with
trusted partners because they assess
more on your credit score because you
know and i know that you're a lot more
than just a freaking number so use a lot
of different inputs
which makes your payment determination
way more accurate so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to
upstart.com yang that's upstart.com
yang don't forget to use our url and let
them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your
loan application go to upstart.com
[Music]
how many times do you simulate
this before i'm assuming thousands
wherever it is or
and but like um how do those simulators
work
and are they are you like practice
landing in like the middle of a desert
um or do you have like a like a i'm
thinking like a movie studio or you can
like a big warehouse where you can
adjust the atmosphere in there to test
how do you guys practice for this okay
well let me tell you
what we don't do well what we can do
because it's too difficult too expensive
and not not
not worth it is to try to to
to exercise that that whole sequence
here on earth
the the conditions on earth of
atmosphere and gravity are so far off
we don't live it's worthless it's
worthless it's expensive
so the best we we do right the worst we
can do
and what we do is first of all for each
component
of of this system we do tests right like
for example for the parachute we do a
test that try
to mimic the conditions when we open the
parachute
as much as we can right to make sure
that it's the right design and is
and is built properly too and the same
with the landing radar
we put the landing radar in the
helicopter and we try to replicate the
conditions that the radar is going to
see on mars and we fly through the
mojave desert under different terrains
you know different velocities and then
and then we process the data from those
tests and we
we build mathematical models of
of of that component for each one of
these components that we test
separately we build mathematical models
and then we put it in
in a simulation right all those
mathematical models we put them together
and then we make the system land in a
simulation
right where we model all the components
and also we have to model
the marginal environment like where
we're landing we're gonna get winds
and the the atmosphere density is
changing right and the
the places where we don't know exactly
where things are which is
we don't know anything exactly we
actually statistically we add noise
we have we are without errors that
we've that try to envelop the
uncertainty
and the error in each component like for
example the the
the winds we don't know exactly so we
add a random component to the winds
and then we we use a technique called
monte carlo which is
from the casino so it's actually it's
after that which essentially it becomes
a statistical
where we make the system land thousands
if not tens of thousands of times
in the simulation and then we look at
statistically which one
landed properly and which one landed you
know failed
right so statistically we can say well
99 you know
nine percent of landed okay but then
you're good and sometimes you know
here there are you know we are only
having success with 90
okay what is that 10 percent that is not
working i said
do we have a deficiency in the uh
in the uh on the uh
simulation or or just simply the design
is improper so we need to go fix the
design
uh uh and so that's that's what we use
that's the best we use
that's why we call it seven minutes of
terror one of the many reasons
is that the we haven't done it
essentially we actually do it the
computer is going to do it but you have
it
right exactly so then that's why we are
so concerned that it's not going to work
because if we
forgot a little piece of physics we have
a small error
in that simulation that doesn't expose
our
our mistake then mars will tell us
about our mistake and it's too late by
then right so
it's and uh so that's that's why it's so
so unnerving it's just the fact that we
the first time we try
is when we try it right in and when we
are
betting all those years of work and
sacrifice in seven minutes
and i i know that feeling where you work
so hard on something and there's an
element of luck to it or
or circumstance but when it hits it's
it's the best feeling in the world
have you worked on projects that have
gone the other way i was never
involved in a in you know working in it
i've always you know
i've been consultant in in one of them i
guess that did not work
but uh all the ones that i worked on
have worked
so i've been successful and it's
actually kind of i mean i'm trying to
still explain to myself why i mean i was
very nervous a day of the landing and it
had nothing to do
in terms of not trusting the the
engineers working on it in this one
uh some of them you know uh my friends
and then
had tremendous respect for them but i
was very nervous and
maybe it's because we you know there are
many reasons why
maybe one was simply you know we just
been so lucky we've been very successful
landing these rovers
it's our it's our luck going to run out
at some point
i know it's not a very scientific way of
thinking right but we are humans after
all
you know with emotions and sometimes
when we
after we finish doing all that we can do
with our brain right
then the heart takes over right and it
starts telling you things
and making you lose sleep at night and
then you got to say no but wait a second
i know that
this is the same as before and we tested
this and we tested and these guys did a
tremendous job in there
and i trust them and they work really
hard and i i saw them doing it
so then you kind of the brain takes over
again and tells the heart you know
we're gonna be fine but then when you
land it's all about the heart right it's
not about the brain
it's room of emotional emotional
scientists and engineers which i love
um i think that's what's so i don't know
endearing about it frankly let me back
up like what what is the um
the purpose of the perseverance rover
which just landed it landed in feb
february 18th of 2021 just a couple
weeks ago
what what's the end goal for nasa and
for for
us to to get from this rover on mars
all of these missions have multiple
goals but there are some main goals the
main goal here is
in the the previous rovers right from
pathfinder
to curiosity they're the objective
they're all associated with the with the
goal of uh
determining whether there was life on
mars
3.5 billion years ago four billion years
ago when the conditions of mars
were you know were very different it was
a you know they had an atmosphere it was
a
they have oceans and lakes and
uh and uh it was a warm planet
and very similar to the same con
to the conditions of earth at that time
where on earth life was starting right
so the question is well if the
conditions were there
then there is a chance that life
actually also
uh originated on mars at the same time
then mars changed
right became lost its atmosphere became
very dry
and cold right and uh but the question
is during that time did life
uh you know originated on mars
and uh and that's a question it's very
important question that the scientists
and not just the scientists but right i
mean the philosophers everybody wants to
know what we are alone in the universe
is is life just a pure
terrestrial phenomena right and and
that's it right i mean it's it's a very
difficult
the condition has to be perfect
incredible and
and only happens in the whole universe
only happen on earth right it's probably
unlikely that that's the case but it
would be awesome to prove that that's
not the case just by showing within our
solar system
that life actually took hold in more
than one place
right so that's why we're interested on
mars now the previous missions after
curiosity
the main objective was not detecting
life itself
it didn't have the capability the
instruments to do that but to detect
whether the
conditions uh for life to
uh to originate on mars happen
in the in the distance parts passed
right so
one of them was finding water that
stayed
did exist right and they found check you
know water exists
you know right ph so not too salty not
too acidic
wow perfect for life you know i i need
it lasted millions of years which is
time is always important in the recipe
of life
all of the things are were there so now
now with perseverance we need to go
answer the
it's time to answer the final question
okay cool
but was there a life or not right and
perseverance is going to try to do that
in two ways
one it has instruments on board more
sophisticated instruments
that work in a different way than the
previous uh to
to look for they call it biosignatures
which are you know again to
non-expert like me they are indirect
evidence that
that you know of minerals and the way
they were deposited
that were the action most likely the
action of biological
uh uh you know processes
right so that's and that's what we call
bios bio signatures
detecting life on mars is very difficult
right but
trying to find bio signatures it's it's
the best we can do at this point
why is detecting life so difficult there
it's
life itself the definition of life is
difficult and uh
and it's not you know it seems that it's
not uh
you know and it's not an easy you know
it's controversial thing
right so the best way to to but and also
because
being able to say there was life on mars
or
be able to say we know a place that
there was life that is not earth it's
such a huge
statement that the amount of proof you
need is is overwhelming right
so the second way that
perseverance is going to help is it's
going to take these samples
of soil and and rock encapsulate them
into in these cylinders and and
and seal them such that another mission
that we are working on it called mars
sample return is going to take these
samples
and bring them back to earth now here on
earth
we have all the instruments
sophisticated instruments we can
make the measurements argue the
scientists with you know and and now you
can
have you know we we feel that if they're
if they're you know if there was live
fossils in that in
those samples will be able to come up
with a scientific consensus
right and uh and try to do bringing
those
instruments to mars is very very
difficult it's much easier to bring a
piece of
mars to the instruments on earth so
that's
the second way that perseverance is
going to help
answer this question
[Music]
are you unhappy with your smile you no
longer have to because
thousands of people have used candid the
clear comfortable removable and
practically invisible
aligners to straighten your teeth and
now
people love their smile seriously like
they sent me these testimonials of real
people with
like their actual stories so justin in
georgia was like hey i used to have a
gap in my front the side
and then uh people were staring at my
mouth all the time and now
canada was a perfect company for me
because you can't you can't stop me from
smiling now it's pretty cool
how much a smile goes a long way um and
canada is a pretty awesome company
they basically pair you with a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement and you have the same
orthodontist who created your plan
from start to finish so you never have
to wonder how you're doing you get
paired with one and it's just six months
you'll start
seeing results way before then and it's
thousands of dollars less
than traditional braces so here's the
deal become your best you
with your best smile start straightening
your teeth today
right now you can save 75 bucks on
candid starter kit go to candidco.com
yang and use the code yang that's
candidco.com
yang use the code yang take advantage of
this limited time offer and save 75
on your starter kit
code
canonco.com
[Music]
i watched a lot of the videos of this
thing that the police public videos from
nasa and the bells and whistles on this
rover
are pretty remarkable for theirs
it's got microphones so we're getting
sound from mars on the first time it can
drive itself
um it's got a helicopter on it to
travel further if it needs to support
and it can drill and get samples and
then you're going to give them you're
going to propel them up to another
rocket ship at some point to send them
home what else so what like in that
context like
please tell me more what this thing can
do but also what is it going to be
i know it landed in a crater like what
is it going to be doing
for the next number of i mean i guess
however long it's going to be there
number of years i guess another
interesting contribution that
perseverance is going to do
is it carries an instrument that is
going to take the
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere and
uh
and extract the oxygen okay and that is
just to prove the concept that
that we can actually generate oxygen
from the mars
atmosphere for astronauts in the future
and for
for breeding but also you can it's part
of the the the fuel
you know to come back home so so so
that's going to be an experiment
uh and i and also as you mentioned it's
going to have a helicopter which is also
an experiment it's not
part of the main scientific goal of the
mission but it's you know once in a
while
we like to do experiments to you know to
enable future missions right that then
will be dedicated to
to to using a helicopter for scientific
purposes
uh flying a helicopter on mars is very
challenging because of what i just told
you before
that the atmosphere of mars has a
density of only one percent so a lot of
people
thought it was impossible but an
engineer did the calculation so you can
is you know it's it's not simple it's
it's really hard you know and adapting
all the equations and all the dynamics
of helicopters to
the martian conditions was a fantastic
job done by
a bunch of you know very talented
engineers at jpl and around
the nation and uh so that's going to
prove that the idea is to prove that
concept
that right so then in the future we can
design missions around that
so um and as far as you know the
activities i mean why they picked that
place
right the gesture or crater is because
you know like we said before
water is important for life and they
believe that in that crater
uh there's there was a river you know
you know again billions of years ago
that
that brought waters into the lake and in
the process
they carry with it you know sediments
that accumulated in the and form a delta
right and that delta uh that you can
actually see in the pictures
right and uh and uh could contain the
the they're very good the materials the
the the
geology of deltas are and the materials
are very good at preserving evidence of
life if there was
life right so it's a perfect place to go
take these samples right and increase
the probabilities
that the sample contains that evidence
those fossils of life
when we bring them back home they've
said that the samples should be
ideally back to earth by 2031 so we got
a ways to go
how long is perseverance the rover
expected to be there and
do you just keep it there forever until
there's a storm or something that wipes
it out or
is there a finite end date all our
missions right when we
we negotiate the mission with with nasa
right or we define
it let's use that word negotiate that
when they find the mission nasa says
this mission in in the approval process
right
uh they there are you know objective
scientific objectives and
and and and on and engineering
objectives
and one of them is the duration of the
mission to be worth doing right
uh and and in this case is one
martian year which is about two earth
years they feel that in that time they
can do
fulfill all the scientific objectives
now
for us engineers that means that we need
to design a vehicle that lasts at least
two
two years but usually it lasts for much
longer right so
uh the the spear and opportunity rovers
were designed
to last three months that's that's what
was required of us
and they lasted many many many years i
think opportunity i think it lasted like
10 years
so chances are that curiosity and
perseverance you know unless there is a
major catastrophe that we not anticipate
um each they should last you know
hopefully a decade right but again the
the
in order to be able to call the mission
a success 100
success it needs to last two earth years
approximately what does it start to look
like like let's say
let's talk about the future a little bit
in the sense that let's say
we do find like absolute proof
that there's life on mars right like we
find
evident we find fossils you find
evidence of conditions that were like
objectively this is where
there was green grass here and whatever
it is
what um how does that affect nasa how
does that affect your funding how does
that what do you think the world starts
to think of your work
if that if that happens well i mean it
would be a tremendous
news by the way i think it would would
be one of the you know people would
study in the books right this is the
first time
you know a thousand years from now right
people will be reading books studying
books and saying this is the mission
that made it happen
right i mean it would be documented in
history
right and the same way the first time
men walked on the moon right so so it
would be i think it would be that big
i think that there was still going to be
a lot of answers right a lot of things
that they're gonna
again this is beyond my field of
expertise by a lot
but i would imagine that would try to
say okay it's life and it wasn't similar
to earth i mean it's a dna or i mean
i'm not sure that they will be able to
answer those questions but they're gonna
try to
imagine to try to pin it down and
but you know studying astrobiology which
is the science of
of understanding what the life happened
anywhere outside earth uh it's no one i
end up there
right i mean uh uh the the other
question for example i mean some people
believe that this life
let's say that there was life on mars
3.5 billion years ago
chances is that on the surface you're
gonna find fossils right because it's
very
very um hostile environment the surface
of mars with the radiation or some
chemistry in the surface that
is practically sterilizing kills it
right
but some people think that that life
could have adapted and now is
in the subsurface so it's possible that
is there might be
life there so then there would be
missions to now
try to drill and you have to drill for
hundreds of meters
right and uh and to to
to actually test the hypothesis right so
that would be a
brand new uh uh you know
uh set of missions that you could do
that
uh also i mean there are other places on
our solar system to study life
and and for example europa which is a
moon of
jupiter that
below a an ice cross there is a
liquid ocean so there's actually liquid
water today
on on europa so it's possible that you
don't live with those
oceans you might have life and one
maybe it could be even more advanced
than just microbes right
so there's plenty of of
you know if well you know being able to
check and say yes life happened
somewhere else
there's still a lot of research that you
can continue doing
and nasa is not all about finding life
elsewhere right we want to understand
how
the solar system form right and um
and uh and the different galaxies so
there we have plenty
we just started right i mean that's we
still have a lot of things to answer
about
about about the universe in your opinion
like how far away
are we from sending humans to mars or
humans to you know bringing
manned missions to some of these places
it's a good question
i don't know exactly i mean nasa's plans
right now is to go back to the moon
right i mean
in this decade i mean that the original
plant under the previous administration
was 2024
uh you know go back with uh astronauts
the first woman on on the moon by 24. 24
probably that not you know that they get
moved
towards the future but hopefully still
within
the short term and uh and the idea is
now to go back to the moon
and not do what apollo did that's just
putting you know the flag and
footprints and take a few pictures and
come back i mean they did a fantastic
job they did some science too but
but the apollo project was you know more
of a
cold war political national pride
contest right so the idea now is to go
back to the moon and stay
and not only stay but also learn to live
of the
uh of the resources in the moon right
the moon has
you know that in the poles has eyes
right in the south pole so the idea is
to
to to have access to that eyes to again
to
convert that into uh oxygen and
uh and and fuel i mean
and uh separating hydrogen and oxygen
you make fuel
and uh so because the idea is when we go
to mars we're going to have to use those
techniques
right and and the best thing would be to
exercise
living of the land on the moon
before we actually attempt to go to the
mars mars where
uh we're gonna have to it's it's so
expensive to
to bring cargo to mars so
that if you have to bring your fuel from
your return fuel you have to bring it
from earth
right it makes it very difficult so it
would be better to actually
like he's illustrated in the movie the
martian they do they illustrate very
well right that you actually send
a factory of fuel ahead of time and you
only send the astronauts right
later when the module for return with
fueled up is ready to come back so
that's kind of the plan but the idea
nasa is first to do it on the moon but
you know there is
like other companies like uh spacex that
they feel that they can
do that much sooner as for nasa this
we're talking about
end of the the next decade uh
elon musk wants to do it sooner and uh
and i i hope the shooter the better but
for all of us
right but it is a very difficult problem
right it's it's
go putting humans on the surface of mars
and
return them safely is it's it's tens if
not hundreds of times
more difficult to do it on the moon so
that's that's all
also because we haven't done it you know
how spacex
and uh whatever jeff pays this company
how are they some of private
attempts at being nasa yeah how have
they uh
have they changed the way you guys
operate have they made your life easier
better more complicated
how's that dynamic on your end people
think that that we
that nasa competes with them and they
don't realize that is is
that that's not the case on the contrary
you know we
we we we have a relationship where we
we help each other in some way phrase
symbiotic
relationship and we want them to succeed
uh like for example you know the the
the commercial cargo and commercial crew
program
to carry uh um
provisions to the space station and and
astronauts right that's that's something
that
nasa started right and uh and have this
public private private partnership with
uh for example with spacex and now
for crew boeing and um
to to try to reduce the cost of doing
that and that has been a tremendous
success
right it has been such a huge success
that now they are applying the same
uh formula right uh to the human landing
system which is the
the the part of the art artemis program
right that brings the astronauts from
orion which will be
in orbit around the moon to the surface
and back right so that
is being you know developed that program
uh using the same uh uh
type of you know relationship with the
private sectors that they
they are using to bring materiel and and
astronauts to the space station
where the this private companies
actually they they
render a service for nasa right so nasa
doesn't take possession of the machine
it's almost like you're paying for you
know i'm gonna pay you to put these
astronauts on the surface and then bring
them back to
to orion and they can do it cheaper
theoretically or
um in partnership right exactly and
actually they can sell that service to
other people and
and actually they they require these
companies to also
make their own investment in this right
because they they're gonna own that
intellectual property so also to put
some skin in the game
right so you want to them to put skin in
the game
so it's a it's a new way of doing things
where we all win
right it's not like not so you know this
is this is what we want
we want also the price the the cost of
the launch vehicles
to come down because our our missions we
you know we contract out to the private
sector our launch vehicle
the the rockets that get us in our way
the cheaper those rockets are
right uh the the more missions we can do
right so so this is all good i mean this
is
it's exactly and actually we in in nasa
we we try to facilitate as much uh you
know
that our you know intellectual property
we develop within nasa
that we transfer that to the private
sector that's what we do that's what we
actually like doing i love
i love that uh so what what scares you
does anything scare you about where this
could be going like anything that
kind of keeps you up at night about the
future of space the future of mars
exploration
this reducing the cost right i mean
sometimes
you know it's not that you take more
risk but you need to be very clever at
you know uh cutting the things that are
not useful
right that are adding bureaucracy but
not safety
right so you have to do surgery you know
cut the you know
cut the fat but don't cut the muscle
sort of thing and
i is it possible that we overdo it right
and uh and we have an accident right and
then
and that that could put some
throw some cold water on the whole thing
right and uh
so we have to be very careful right i
mean it's good to reduce the cost but we
should make sure that we don't try to do
so much that that we compromise safety
no nasa is all over it they you know
they're managing that
right but but that's that's that is uh
that's the tricky part nasa to me is
one of few government organizations we
have that actually is forward-looking
which means by definition it's
optimistic we're investing in our future
what is exciting you 10 20 years from
now what would be
the perfect outcome what would get you
really excited about the future space
first of all i would love to see humans
on the moon again right you know we
waited so long
for that right so that is uh i mean i'm
looking forward to that
and uh i'm looking forward to to bring
those samples back from mars right i
mean that's gonna be fantastic imagine
you know
you know seeing this piece of mars that
you know that uh that were brought up
with all these machines all these
robotic machines
and we've been working and talking about
this for decades
right and uh so that excites me a lot
and there are
there are hope there are so many
missions you know as i mentioned before
this uh europa lander europa
mission you know to put a package of in
scientific instruments on the surface of
europa
is super exciting and uh we would like
to do a mission like that we're waiting
to see what are the priorities
in nasa you know we there's a process
where they choose the priorities for the
future missions
and i'm hoping that that's one of them
uh i think that it would be a very cool
place to go visit you know imagine
landing in a foreign place like
that right the more places we land
because i mean i think that we as humans
we we like to project us right i'm in
the surface of mars
in the surface of the moon on the
surface of of europa
you know what would if we were standing
there and we looked around what it would
look like right
so i i think that there's there's still
a lot of that to do
and uh and explore and it's very
exciting to also to see
so many young kids now getting into this
right i mean when you go visit
um the spacex plant in you know in
hawthorne here in captain
and it's they're all young you know and
and and
it's it's fantastic i mean i i think
that we're going through a great period
of space exploration
and there are more players uh there are
other countries too that are
are also you know expanding their
activities
and um so there's a lot of there's a lot
of you know
uh finally i think we're seeing the
explosion that we wanted to see
a few decades ago is is happening and
it's kind of like a
it taken its own life right that's
that's
uh that's the thing that is exciting
it's not it's no longer the
the you know the the big governments
that i have to be
pushing and pushing and putting money it
feels like finally
we we let we literal fire and the fire
is just going
right and and uh and that's all good i
think about that a lot how many little
boys and girls watched your video
of it landing or i've looked at elon
musk and what spacex is doing or even
jeff and blue origin and
say i want to do that i want to get
involved in that i get you know
and that is the best part of this future
so here's what do we get we'll
in 10 years i'll bring you back we'll be
back on
you can tell me hopefully they will give
you a space rock
from mars i hope they do that or a moon
rock or something
i know i'm sure they won't but maybe
after they've done all their tests maybe
they'll distribute it up to the people
that have earned it you have
you would have earned it sir um i will i
will i would be happy with a piece of a
grain
just a little bit okay great just a
little yeah like a
sliver some mars dust um but
look miguel um i can't tell you how much
on a personal level like i
i think you're a real-life superhero
there are people like you
doing work that in many ways is unsung
and it's unknown it's behind the scenes
but
without you and your colleagues i know
you're you're there's a lot of people
in your team it is a team sport let me
tell you i guess it's a team sport i
mean there are
i mean there's only sometimes there are
faces like you know mine lately because
of the
the the silly tiktok that my daughter
put
but you know what whatever works if it
is good to inspire new generations
and uh and you know and uh and and unite
us in these difficult times that we're
living these days uh
it's true you were like you were a
source of hope for me i hope you're so
so hope an inspiration for a lot of
people listening so miguel
congrats thank you keep us posted on
what you find
um if you find aliens you have my email
you guys just let me know i won't go
public i think you'll find out
[Music]
you